I'm a strong believer like there are
notes here here's a thing you have two
excuses yeah you have a good excuse of
the bear excuse and the Internet is two
excuses as a comic you know I'm saying
you could have a show like at night and
say yeah sure at 12 o'clock you just
found out like one of your aunts or
uncle's or whatever just passed away
right you've got a good excuse not to go
to that show you know you know I'm it's
um it's not I'm not feeling right that's
my excuse is still excuse and you got a
bad excuse not to go to a show you know
I'm saying oh man I got a cold or
something something stupid you know but
at the end of day is still excuses so as
much as we're we not just black people
and just for anybody stop making excuses
yeah it's so easy makes what you gonna
do what you gonna do and that goes I
relate that to comedy you see you've
been in the game for a long time you see
my folks trying to get stage time and
stuff and they say oh yeah but they
don't really like me in that Club they
don't really mess with women and then
you access same comic where do you
before I perform I just one cup is over
mic and you say how did you do all my
set was okay no [ __ ] getting
enough yeah you know I'm saying and I
tell this all young common with you know
anything any doors you want opened it's
gonna come through the microphone yeah
when you rippin when you're not just
fitnah 50 I'm talk about when you
demolishing everywhere you can't be
denied yeah you don't say don't make
excuses make yourself undeniable you
don't mean okay I don't do five spots a
week I do too but we need to know two
spots kill him yeah those two spots are
turned into three spots and five spots I
even use myself as an example with me in
the comedy scene in California I came up
as a New Yorker when I first came in
people knew me from the Chappelle show
right they don't need a lot of people
didn't know me to stand up and a lot of
clubs didn't know oh he's a funny dude
on TV but whatever and I used to drive
down Sunset Hollywood and now you see
the names up there on it on the marquee
yeah and I'm look at those names and I'm
not disrespecting them like this I'm on
that level right I'm on Tasha be Tia I'm
not I'm not making excuses I'm not gonna
say [ __ ] that I don't want to do the go
do the work to get there and
I told myself I want to be when I'm in
town I want to be on every marquee
that's a test of who's popping in the
city yeah
and it might not mean a lot to a lot of
people but for me when I can drive down
sunset and I see I'm on the marquee
at the store go to laughs Agra see I'm
on the marquee laughs at you go to the
improv I say I'm at the marquee at the
improv go - haha suppose it caught a lot
of people [ __ ] yeah this is a great
place whereby when you see that you feel
a comments and you feel accomplished and
you say yourself I didn't make excuses
and I deal with it a couple times like
oh they don't want to they don't wanna
let me on and they let that [ __ ]
go on right you just take your lumps
come back the next day and you build
your [ __ ] yeah and the reason I'm saying
is like in life period
there are literally there's no more
excuses
that's true if you're gonna do it you're
not gonna do it yeah and you look around
as we got too many examples I mean
outfield we got examples of people that
we don't necessarily agree with like say
from stand-up but you got now we're we
an age where you could make yourself the
[ __ ] on your phone yeah in front of your
computer it's not the time when I came
out with three or four networks we're on
your own network so you definitely you
got people at six nine is a perfect
example yeah it wasn't trying to [ __ ]
with him the energy went round [ __ ] with
him we say I'm gonna [ __ ] her myself
I don't need y'all feet yeah that's a
great statement I'm gonna [ __ ] up myself
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] myself and I can
make a habit no yeah I don't know I had
a manager before I don't have a manager
right now and I had a manager and I
remember one time I had this thing I was
trying to do when I was traveling on the
road and I was having and I was like I
want to shoot it and put it on a YouTube
and he's like well let's put it together
and go out and shop it around so then we
did that for like a year and nobody you
know it was back and forth but in the
meantime in that year I didn't you know
I did it some but I was waiting now more
than for these networks to decide if I
was gonna have an opportunity whereas if
I would have just been making at the
time that still would have been huge
then it would have been something at the
finish line whereas instead I let them
decide okay the finish line is now and
we don't want your own thing yeah I'll
give you two great examples of that bill
burr Kevin Hart when I was doing when we
were doing Chappelle show at the time
bill Burt was bubbling bill burr was
bubbling he wasn't tense
that 10 times fast no the reason why I'm
saying it now he was bubble yeah saw him
in the club use like you go see certain
club so you like this this my father's
gonna blow this my father's gonna blow
but he didn't have the TV and all that
but you know what's coming right and we
were done Chapelle show we were making
money spell shop but not a lot of money
we needed a tour I came up with the idea
of doing a nun rich [ __ ] to her yeah
you know I'm saying in a rich [ __ ] tore
the the to two drawers at the time with
me and Charlie and I could have ran away
I could have went to my local but I said
not Bill burr is an animal let's not
just do a show people coming for the
novelty of the show yeah let's give them
a show
where this show is fire from beginning
to end and that's what we had on rich
[ __ ] tour I think this is the first
time Bill burr was we would we ran this
shift like a year and a half
Charlie Murphy would bill Burt you know
you know this is funny bill burr was a
feature Wow and I was headlining and
I'll tell you you know you talk about no
excuses
imagine going on every night for a year
behind bill burr thought that there was
no day you could take off yeah you
didn't have a you go out and party get
all [ __ ] up you got a hangover the
next day guess what happened and this
happened to me over times like yeah it
was funny but that white boy if you
don't I'm saying and a point I'm making
is he knew his features physical because
me and try was on I really my fate all
is yes it was just it was pandemonium
but Bill burr was a one with the comment
cards you know I'm saying filling him
out the emails I'm like yo you worry
about the email [ __ ] making people to be
coming to see you forever
he was dude that was doing the email car
and he started building that base yeah
he stopped doing that base and then when
you stopped in that base people started
rhyming with you and then you because
then you win like comedian of the Year
in the Montreal Comedy Festival you
gonna build that point he knew what he
wanted
early on a lot of people don't Kevin
Hart as much as people want to touch
about Kevin Kevin Hart was the same
situation
Kevin Hart was always down with whatever
didn't the newest thing was was myspace
right
I remember Kevin Hart has 60,000
followers on Twitter and he was found by
can get you some follows now that dudes
out of he's he just on another level
yeah rock star but he play
and like you were saying about waiting
for the network they didn't wait those
people didn't wait so by time the
network's got caught up to them they was
already I was under arrest it was
already ready you know I'm saying and
that's what you said is important you
know I'm saying but like a lot of times
in this business we want to swing for
the gate all the time yeah sometime a
base hit is good sometime a bun is good
but you got to know that yeah that's
what separates two different people now
you look at Bill burr I look at Bill
burr 13 years ago vest he was on he was
a opening on our show and then is just
doing doing Madison Square Garden and
this here's another thing how stuff's
supposed to inspire you I see that I
know how funny I know how funny is it
but it gives you a sense of Noda you
from a place where it could happen right
you know I'm saying you look at bill
burr he's like this do we were gonna st.
Claire it could happen who's gonna put
the work in right you know good evening
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one